hey excuse me excuse me
he's like huh yeah right
he goes i just want to say i'm a huge
fan right and see this and once you hear
stevie's voice you know it's not yeah
right he's like um
i'm not who you think i am i'm not
famous right
[Laughter]
this guy's face just drops like crazy
embarrassing yeah first of all oh my god
have you heard the phrase not all of us
look alike yeah and you're adding the
asian in five
four three
two one hello everybody welcome to an
episode of the genius brain podcast
all sundays at 12 p.m
i love you very much people this is what
the third is year four i'm four years
three forty three and a half years [ __ ]
it's been a while well this is my second
year coming into the podcast i think i
first came last march yeah yeah it might
be around like four years almost four
years now which is kind of [ __ ] crazy
just i mean it worked out a lot better
than having to edit a [ __ ] vlog yes i
tell you that i started doing just like
these quick little vlogs just when i
have a thought randomly right i'm like
man i forgot how annoying this stuff is
that yeah
i was like oh my god i color correct all
this [ __ ] like oh my god that's annoying
so much [ __ ] work dude like
it's not okay
like on a
singular level it's not like that hard
right but if you have to do it twice a
week yeah
it's like holy [ __ ]
even like with the podcast and just
going thinking about it too it's like do
you have any idea how many times i had
to lay my opinions about things like
constantly
like
once again i i'm never ever going to
complain about my life i i really
appreciate everything that i get to do
and you know even being able to do stuff
where this space makes sense and it
works it's nice you know i [ __ ] love
it but it's kind of interesting that i
have a certain fan base that comes in
every week for me to [ __ ] make them
giggle and laugh or like give them
perspective
one thing i will say though that i do
want to address just because you know
people have been writing me comments and
messages about this
they're like dude how come you always
just [ __ ] on muriel like all the time
it's like
she's on my podcast
that's what i do
this is not our relationship
conversations you dummies it's like
behind the scenes you're just like oh
you're an idiot yeah
that's the thing like you call her a
[ __ ] like in the beginning
are you are you dumb
like
they're like dude she's telling her
stuff and you're ragging on yeah cause
i'm giving her [ __ ] on the podcast we're
just having a banter back and forth like
i i've literally called abuser
why does she stay with such an abusive
man she needs to open her eyes
you know i know she's asian but open her
eyes a little bit
it's like dude she knows it we get it
like nope nobody's defending nick when i
call him a [ __ ] yeah
like
how come you're not defending nick
they're like oh it's it's different
because it's just not on this podcast
when she's on this podcast she's not my
my fiancee
she's her co-host she's my co-host
like
that's work this is we're doing work
talk you're not gonna see all the
smoochy smoochy [ __ ] on this [ __ ]
podcast we don't and this is the
weirdest thing you can find that [ __ ]
i'm pouring up yeah
it's so common you'll see that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hacked in my icloud pics
but the weird thing is too like you know
i always tell people too and i feel like
a good portion is just like new new
subscribers or something it's like
i'm always very adamant to let people
know like you get to see what i let you
see
yeah yeah that's so real because i mean
we just talked about the matrix
and just going back to the idea of what
the matrix is is like literally for some
reason people can't tell the difference
between someone's reality yeah and like
just entertainment yeah and just to like
defend some of the viewership i think
it's because we do have very real
conversations it does get serious or
whatever but then it's not like hey
we're going to riff right now
you're not going to do that yeah right
if you you know riffing is when you get
it in your head you say the first thing
yeah do you think like when mario's
telling me about her trip to toronto i'm
like oh that's so dumb no
i'm listening to it i'm like yo that's
dope that you went there we've already
had this conversation before you just
they're they're retelling it's not like
okay she got back yeah toronto don't
tell me don't tell me until we're on the
mic it's like of course you guys have
had this conversation yeah she's just
like hey can i tell you about my dad go
shut the [ __ ] up
you know when we're supposed to have our
real conversations yeah we're supposed
to have our real conversations on the
podcast the whole world and our fake
stuff isn't private yeah
the [ __ ]
like of course i'm [ __ ] giving her
[ __ ] and i'm poking fun of her it's how
everybody is treated on this podcast
because this is the [ __ ] platform for
that you will never ever be privy to our
private conversations and how we really
are because that's for us this is your
own little like loitering parking lot
yes 7-eleven where you you go with your
buddies to get a slurpee and you just
chill and hang out at the parking lot
and you just talk a whole lot of
[ __ ] it's just [ __ ]
majority of the times it's nonsense and
by the way too one of the things that i
wanted to address they go oh how come on
the podcast muriel doesn't open up about
her life you just talk so much i'm like
because she doesn't want to [ __ ] tell
you about your personal [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] dude like she comes
on as a favor to me
you know a lot of the times when mario
comes on it's because somebody has
yeah
this is because yeah who else you're
going to get exactly so she as a favor
to me she just comes on and then she
asks a lot of questions and allows me to
riff off her and then we have a
conversation like it's you she's not an
entertainer and i don't think people
understand it yeah they're so used to
seeing youtube couples all right right
so it's like bart and geo are you they
that's their career yeah you know that's
both of their careers because ariel
is not an entertainer like they make
money you're not gonna know 90 of the
stuff that she thinks how she feels and
stuff about her personal life you will
never know that stuff you know why
because she's a normal human being yeah
she chooses not to let those things out
because number one
look you [ __ ] can't even deal
with public [ __ ] scrutiny yeah so
what the [ __ ] are you to [ __ ] like
ask her why she why she's not telling
these stories and you know from first
person view when you have a guest come
on and it's actually their first podcast
ever my god like what's that like yeah
it's just it's like pulling teeth yeah
you know yeah and and so like people
have to understand like this is it
actually you you have to get acclimated
to this water yeah you know uh it's one
thing like even my first time i was
nervous as [ __ ] but then um
you know over time i've been on here now
like since last march i was just like
natural it's natural i went drunk
yeah
so it's only fair you know
that mario comes on is actually like a
[ __ ] blessing for you because how
many people could you know just be like
oh [ __ ] i had a guest fall out yeah like
i'm
i'm not going to explain this anymore if
you see marielon and you guys enjoy it
enjoy for what it is you're not gonna
really get to know her personally like
you will me i'm okay i'm i'm an open
book but even then to my open you still
don't know like
70 of me yeah like i'm only telling you
personal like very weird stories that
i'm okay telling yeah right you're not
gonna know everything that's why it's
gotta [ __ ] suck for people who create
a character for themselves out there and
then like people meet them in real life
and then
they treat them like their character and
then all of a sudden the creator is like
offended yeah and it's like you did this
on yourself man everybody thinks you're
like this way yeah like when people come
up to me and they go like i thought
you'd be a lot meaner i'm like i get it
yeah you know i i get it roast me yeah
dude so
i'll get a lot of comments about like
send food stuff or when we're doing um
when foodie calls and they go oh david
doesn't like to being approached i'm
like that's the joke in the video
that's the joke it's like when somebody
comes to the screen we're like what the
[ __ ] are you doing here that's the
ongoing bit yeah like if you're a fan
do you guys understand that i owe you my
life
don't i'm i'm not like that like look i
get it though you know but
like the the weird thing is it's like oh
my god he's gonna [ __ ] yell at me and
like yeah if i yell at you just
understand you're part of the joke so
enjoy it like after the cameras are off
right
say hi it's normal it's a part of the
bit like i should i've explained it and
also i shouldn't have to explain that
yeah that's when you lose the idea of a
joke where it's just not funny anymore
that's when it sucks it's like
once you have to explain joke it loses
its appeal it loses its fervor and it's
like
it's it's
it's like why do i have to catch you up
to speed here man like everyone else is
already here yeah it's like and i've
always and i've said it in a million
videos before it's like you do
understand that the career that a lot of
these youtubers have like this is this
is one of the most honest relationships
it's like i have a lifestyle because you
watch and support yeah there is no other
way around it yeah i create stuff for me
but because you enjoy the stuff that i
create i get to be who i am so there is
no idea of me walking around thinking
that i'm anywhere near better than any
of my viewers if anything you're better
than me because you allow me to live the
life that i have yeah so it's a
lifestyle of appreciation one of the
things that people do have to remember
and i'm going to reiterate this is that
once again even for me the stuff that i
put out social media is not real you get
a glimpse of life and you get to see
what i allow you to see yeah so when
marielle comes on
and you wonder why i'm talking so much
because
guys
she's not comfortable talking about all
of her personal details yeah you will
never ever get to know that stuff
because
my lady is a very well-balanced human
being which is why i get to be as
chaotic as i am yeah you know she's the
yin to my [ __ ] yang so if you're
wondering why like okay well on the
podcast she's asking more questions and
not really answering her our own is
because she's not comfortable and
rightfully so she's not in entertainment
personal information that goes out on
this space also will affect her personal
job right
you know like why don't people like it's
it's the same people who go online and
they go let me tell y'all something i
[ __ ] hate wendy's [ __ ] wendy's is the
worst company ever and the next day they
go into wendy's for work yeah
they're fired yeah
what happened
it's like you know all those people that
[ __ ] on wendy's they actually
work for themselves
no they can't get fired by us
it's like it's like one of those
situations it's the idea that a lot of
people still
like people have to come back to earth
like your personal information doesn't
have to be out there you don't have to
let people know your thoughts all the
[ __ ] time which is why a lot of
celebrities often forget that when they
tweet [ __ ] you know they go this is how
the world should be
shut the [ __ ] up remember gal gadot when
she's saying that stupid song
with all her [ __ ] celebrity friends
yeah how detached was that
you know it's [ __ ] insane that uh
it's not like it's the people in
who read the comments and people put
themselves in in front of the camera too
it's like
their sense of reality can can be in the
same space too where it's like i need to
say this somebody needs to hear and so
they'll write this long-ass [ __ ]
comment to like rebut whatever you have
to say and said and you'd be like your
only answer is like man it was a [ __ ]
joke yeah
get the [ __ ] over yourself yeah it's
like just [ __ ] relax man that's why
it's even hard for me to be sometimes
like
in
because i have like social anxiety yeah
um
i manage it pretty well just because i
can like mentally get myself into a
space where i can deal with it and it's
like all the energy yes and then i don't
want to be around people for the next
few days
but
the reason why too i kind of figured a
lot of my social anxiety comes from is
the fact that i'm also becoming an adult
now where i'm it's not that i care what
people think but i'm also mindful about
how people feel right right and
understandably so within the
entertainment space i am somebody that
is much like the matrix an anomaly
[Laughter]
you know
if i don't like somebody it doesn't
matter what your career is what
opportunities you can create for me
you're not going to suck butt i'm not i
just because
my boss is you like
you know like i answer to this crowd
here like i get to create content freely
there is it's to be honest with you a
lot of youtubers and social media people
were spoiled in that sense yeah in a
good way we get to create stuff without
red tape the only red tape that's there
is stuff that we create for ourselves we
can literally create content whenever
the [ __ ] that we want so when i go into
a space where people say okay
we're gonna have this mixer uh these
this is this person you go make sure you
talk to them i'm like
no
talk to my friends yeah you know if we
happen to cross paths and we chop it up
great if my goal is to this guy has
money for a film and i want to talk to
him then maybe i will yeah but at the
end of the day i can't not be myself i'm
just it just it feels like a waste of my
life force so so speaking of social
social interactions
uh
i went to an event that you didn't go to
this year
um
we went i went to the
what the character media gala
is that what it's called now well no
it's called the unforgettable gala
held by character media yeah so it used
to be called the korean yes right korean
was like this publication for korean
americans then they expanded to just
generally asian americans and right now
you can really see that they're just
trying to
just be asian asian right yeah because
uh they also celebrate like asians doing
big things that are just from asia too
yeah right
um so this is today we had the the
laboratory scientists who created
curriculum with ideas
you made such an impact on our culture
and our way of life
you change the way we think and
in fact feel creation changed the world
so so so the unforgettable gala is like
the bet awards for asians right it's
just an award for being asian yes right
so
i i went to my first one like
11 years ago like 2009 i think
this podcast is brought to you by cbd
farmhouse my friends if you haven't
heard me talk about this stuff right
here
well then you don't know me at all and
this is an easy easy ad placement for me
to do because i use this stuff on the
daily whether it's their sleepytime
gummies their tinctures their topical
ointments whatever you name it but right
now the product that i love the most is
the sleepy time gummies because i have
been having a lot of trouble sleeping
lately specifically because of work and
my my time schedule has been all messed
up
these things knock me out and the best
part about it is it helps me wake up
without feeling groggy i love it if
you're sore you guys can use their
freezing roll-on you could use their
topical creams whatever you want cbd
farmhouse has it and guess what for my
listeners out there if you guys want to
try their products and you are sworn in
and you guys are convinced because i use
it all the time guess what you can get
15 off by using my code brain on their
website
cbdfarmhouse.com enter codebrain to get
15 off once again that's
cbdfarmhouse.com
enter codebrain to get 15 off i love
this stuff and i know for a fact you
will too whether you have anxiety muscle
aches pains whatever you need to chill
out cbd farmhouse has it for you
love you [ __ ] um and then like the
year couple after two i i it's because i
did these like a commercial contest for
general
and the finalists got to go and i went
two years in a row for that yeah and
then the next year i went with you
and dan i presented an award to psy
digitally yeah
you didn't show up yeah that's another
thing
so many years that i've gone so many
people don't show
up so it's kind of like
like yeah you know like who doesn't show
up for the bet awards if they're they're
black right like they all like oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah and so um
it's it's super hoity toity pretty much
it's a black tie event this is why i
don't go like the two times that i went
i was forced to wear clothes
and i just
i was forced to wear clothes that's it
yes i was forced to wear slacks and a
tie and a vest and
i just
by the way
i don't dislike the event i think the
event's perfectly fine like you know
good food free alcohol yeah you know
people are there to uh celebrate each
other i
i don't know what it is man i don't like
the concept of awards for yeah it's
self-maspiratory yes that's what it
feels like and like i said to take this
with a grain of salt i'm only telling
you not how you should feel is how i
personally feel so
okay actually say what you have to say
about that
that's it okay yeah because uh
uh i went
so it was last month i went and uh
chimio yang won an award for
his tv work and stuff stuff like that
yeah yeah so it's not it's not like oh
best actor in a thing right best what no
it's just um the
the
groundbreaking award like a new rookie
on the scene who who's making big waves
right yeah and then they'll have one
who's make it's just it's not like how
well you do it's like how you're
impacting the culture which is legit you
know
um so
uh jimmy yo yang won one for com for
comedy
and part of his speech was just like you
know this whole thing like he said like
i don't know why
you know we do this so maspatory
but if you're the one getting
masturbated it's pretty good yeah
[Laughter]
so i mean
like it
it was hilarious then um the the other
part that i critique like every year
every [ __ ] year every time there's a
presenter on stage you know to comment
and talk and speak and read the [ __ ]
lines and [ __ ] and present awards
everyone's [ __ ] talking at their
table
everyone's just battling like no one
stays quiet just to watch people are
talking during their presentation yeah
like the whole like literally it gets
kind of loud to the point where even
the presenters are like uh guys
see and this goes back to i guess the
asians in the library was
i true she i guess she had a [ __ ]
point didn't she point yep and it goes
back to me in that [ __ ]
theater with those two chinese people
behind me just yeah
maybe we do talk a little too much huh
yeah man so
like it that that was pretty bothering
some for me because even
when we went back in the day i think it
was like 2012 right
[ __ ] my hero legendary comic artist
jim lee was going up to accept an award
because he had just become the [ __ ]
lead editor of dc he was a major move
from marvel to dc and he [ __ ]
revamped dc's look with his dope ass
[ __ ] illustrations and they were
[ __ ] awarding him for it
and while he was up there giving his
speech
uh one of clara's [ __ ] super fans
came i was like oh my god clara
and i couldn't hear a goddamn word jim
lee was saying and i'm like i just want
to be like shut the [ __ ] up my hero's on
stage please and they didn't change 10
years later they're still [ __ ]
yapping it up that was also too like one
of my big gripes is like
you know if you're going to make it a
classy event be classy
[Laughter]
pick which side of the [ __ ] fence
you're on if this is something where i'm
supposed to dress up like this is a
black tie affair
and you guys are just [ __ ] rambling
through all these accolades and awards
where you're trying to show people this
like respect and love it's like shut the
[ __ ] up then yeah you know like pick
your side of the fence is this a [ __ ]
ratchet vietnamese wedding or are we
doing straight up an award show because
i would love the ratchet vietnamese
wedding
[ __ ] let's go because if i could show
up in like my secret society gear just
you know i'm looking decent i'll get the
nice fade i'll look clean and i'm
allowed in then let's do it well there's
a few people people went quiet for which
was the panda express founders
everyone paid their respects today yeah
you want to talk about something that
changed the world bigger than [ __ ]
kovid let's talk about pancakes express
dude they they made chinese-american
like food legit you know they invented
orange chicken
like that's the crazy thing ever that
not a lot of people realize they're the
ones who started that [ __ ] orange
chicken is delicious [ __ ] delicious
shout outs to those [ __ ] asian
american kids on that buzzfeed video huh
nobody would eat this stuff real chinese
people wouldn't like this at all and you
always said you had their uncle it's
still good yeah it's delicious stop
[ __ ] kidding yourselves that's why we
aren't ashamed to say mcdonald's is
delicious as well let's just keep it
real yeah i just there's something about
me and like
yeah it's just that self-masturbatory
thing right and like i said when you're
at that award show because i see posts
where people are like yo like i love and
respect why were you talking through
their whole speech then yeah so what the
[ __ ] are you talking about if you really
gave them respect and you really cared
about them like would you be having
these million side conversations not
even looking at them receive their award
this is what i'm talking about like
social media is not real if you were at
that [ __ ] event like i was for those
two years you would see exactly what i
experienced just like
you
people are either here just there to
network to get their [ __ ] name up to
feel like they're very important to walk
this red carpet but you're not really
there to celebrate these people
achievements you're there to celebrate
yourself
and i dislike that and you know what
this is not indicative of this event
this is a lot of events are like this
stuff right and once again if you enjoy
this that's hey
i have no judgment against you i get it
i just don't like it i feel like they
just kind of lose control of the
audience which is weird um tell them all
to shut the [ __ ] up or beat them with
the bamboo stick they they film it now
at the same place oh not filament they
they have it at the same place as the
golden globes
uh at the beverly hilton yeah so it's
nice it's actually really fancy now it's
just yeah the it just seems like the
audience can't get their [ __ ] together
every time yeah man just like i i don't
know man it's just one of those things i
know there's a lot of people there who i
love and respect and
and you know because of the recent wave
of all this like representation stuff
there's people who were going before are
there now yeah yeah oh yeah so like uh
shanghi
um
got a couple awards
right so they gave simu like uh
not i don't i forget it's like
breakthrough actor or something i did
like i said it's not best actor awards
they're just like giving it to people
who made a big culture making big
culture impact yeah she made a huge
culture
got a huge uh big award and ovation too
and
i i kind of saw that like as much as we
personally just don't like it as a film
like that's the place where it's going
to get celebrated hell yeah yeah it
should rightfully so yeah where it was
like the people were on their feet and
like
like showing their real love to the
shangji cast that they showed up
except for
aquafina she was i think she was doing
something else yeah she's i think she's
filming something right now when she's
not filming something killing it yeah so
um it's
it's
really high class it looks super
expensive but uh and they were sponsored
by remy martin right so each table had a
bottle remy i told you let's do it
[ __ ] vietnamese wedding style dude
yeah and i got sick a lot of people got
sick there there was a lot of people you
could see just laying out like oh no
[Music]
invited to this [ __ ]
because dude this guy has been doing so
much for the community yeah he's
actually worthy of being up on stage he
is literally in the cold in protest and
support for a woman who got
beaten senseless with the brick yeah
every day until her husband said hey
i don't want you to do this anymore
because i feel that my wife wouldn't
want
you young people to stand out here in
the cold dang so he was doing it
non-stop so i mean you want to talk
about celebrating somebody from the
asian american community you better
start with that [ __ ] right there
yeah you talking about somebody who's
changed his life well i'll say that it's
not a social award yeah
it is a
hollywood asians award yeah it's just
this is the idea too of of
maybe it's the thing of just like
it just sounds like somebody trying to
say oh look at me i'm also important too
it's like who are you whose approval are
you looking for you don't need anybody's
approval i think one of the things i
really liked about like asian american
culture was the fact that it's true like
we kind of did things on the down-low
right so somebody
said oh you're [ __ ] dumb you don't
know [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] asian dude
what do you [ __ ] know it's like dude
i don't have the business in your
[ __ ] block yeah
you're a peasant don't talk to me yeah
you know so we kind of did things
through action and stuff but once again
it's okay it's it's cool to celebrate it
and stuff like that yeah um i i think
it has its purpose
it's just me being there this year was i
felt so out of place this time
you know because look i ran into a lot
of old friends
that i don't talk to anymore
and realized um
yeah like do i want to
hang out still like actually not really
not really dog i i won't i won't out who
this hit listen i know a lot of [ __ ]
about people
but you know your brother your guy's not
choosing war but like there was this one
uh actress that i know that was at this
[ __ ] event
and this is where i go back to social
media not being real
this person was going on this diatribe
talking to this person behind me and she
was this like was behind me yeah and was
talking about how
they don't believe in sex before
marriage even though i know like 30
people this woman has banged
i
had a social event
at the korean gala at the courthouse oh
so she was being like jesus a little
helper out there
she was spreading the gospel i spit my
drink out
[Laughter]
literally was going on this whole
diatribe talking to this other person
calling
yeah like you know like jesus christ i
changed my life like like i'm a really
hardcore follower of like christianity
and like god like i don't understand why
people can't like
you know like i understand like sex is a
temptation but i personally don't
believe in sex before marriage when i
literally know seven dicks that went in
her mouth
it's like why are you you took my boy's
v card yeah
i'm like why are you voluntarily opening
this information to that that girl
didn't even ask
he's changing me
you know listening to that too it's like
are you trying to
show everybody how how [ __ ] pious and
religious you are and how amazing you
are yeah it's just like hey how are you
doing actually
you know
you know but this is it's like that
stuff too and then like
yeah i i'm gonna stick to the people
that i enjoy and i appreciate and i
don't want to do that hey man it's been
so good i don't like doing that you guys
eventually will reach that point in your
life too i think the only person i was
actually really happy to see was justin
yeah he actually won an award too for
director he should have won award every
year yeah
he uh um
he gave a pretty good speech too where
he was
kind of talking about because his past
experiences at korean uh gala was just
like he would just get wasted and [ __ ]
up his presence one of the funniest
things this will ever did was at
collaboration he had a nipple tassels on
yeah
[Laughter]
that was he went to like a lisa ling
event where in a teddy bear suit and
tried to break dance when he can't break
that
dude justin's hilarious dude i know you
see this guy as like a director of these
amazing films but he's one of the
funniest [ __ ] dudes i've ever met in
my life i think there was i don't know
if it was a collaboration but there was
another one where like uh
they were he was a i think he was a
judge
right it's like him and then a couple
other asian american celebrities or
something and they whoever was hosting
put the mics in their mouths like hey
what do you have to say and like what do
you think about being here when we put
the mic to justin he went
suck my [ __ ]
let's just say this guy has grown up
but by the way
this is why i love justin though justin
is justin dude
he's such a fun fun [ __ ] guy
apologetically yeah dude he's such a fun
[ __ ] guy man he's always been that
way and you see like the type of films
and perspective that he has now is such
a cool thing to see man
it's really really fun yeah and
so uh man there's another thing so
in this event literally every asian
american is there yeah right and um but
there's also a lot of non-asians because
um
this one guy right he's this white actor
he's a good-looking guy right apparently
he's on a couple shows
on two of the award winnings right um
i think they're both netflix and they're
both asian american leads and he's on
both shows so he got invited to the gala
right
and so i was with my brother-in-law
stevie
so
if you know stevie yes he looks like
bobby lee
yes he does so
this actor
i was with stevie we were trying to head
out
and he he was wide-eyed coming to him
right and even my sister sora was like i
saw him coming from a mile away and i
walked away to save myself from the
embarrassment she like she knew this was
going to happen oh my god this guy came
up he put his hands on stevie he's like
hey excuse me excuse me
he's like huh yeah right
he goes i just want to say i'm a huge
fan right and see this and once you hear
stevie's voice you know it's not
right he's like um
i'm not who you think i am i'm not
famous
[Laughter]
this guy's face just drops like crazy
embarrassing yeah like first of all oh
my god
have you heard the phrase not all of us
look alike yeah and you're at an asian
american wardrobe where 99 of us are
asian and you pull that off
i would literally scream out loud i was
like this guy thought i was bobby lee
everybody
no
he
instantly turned around and walked away
the other way he was so embarrassed
that's hilarious
hey man oh my god kudos to you though
because i'll tell you this i've done
that a few times i don't do that stuff
anymore i've done i [ __ ] up so many
you know in high school once i so there
was two people in my high school that
were two short asian guys they were the
same height they looked very similar but
only one of them was my friend you
didn't just mix them up so
one time after school i [ __ ] ran up
to this fool
i picked him up and i chucked him
like i threw him like a doll he was just
a stranger
[Laughter]
and it was not him
i had a 50 50 chance
of who this i will still remember this
till this [ __ ] day one of the most
mortifying experiences ever
some random guy me
picks you up in midair and wwe [ __ ]
throws you and the reason why i did that
was because the day before he was over
at my house
we were [ __ ] around and doing um
when i was a freshman in high school but
we were doing um
what do you call a smackdown type of
[ __ ]
yeah and then i [ __ ] did this this
like somersault roll
and then
he was supposed to like catch my fall
with a bunch of pillows but he moved the
pillows and i smashed my head into the
wall oh my god so i was like bleeding on
the temple of my head it was just fat
kicking
and then my parents beat my ass
because i put a hole in the wall and so
i was like
and so i saw this after school i
literally [ __ ] picked him up and i
threw him in the mid in midair and i was
like [ __ ] got you full this dude
he goes what the hell
it's just like a computer
i didn't know what to say and the guy
just so pissed he picked up his backpack
and stormed off because i think he
thought i was bullying you yeah
i thought you were my friend
dude that's an allegory to even what we
were talking about earlier man it's just
something you do with your boys it was
your safe space it's just the wrong
person you're taking it the wrong way
i like to hit me like oh yeah you just
throw your friend in midair
yeah this is what i do with my boys look
at my tempo
he did this to me yesterday he said i
don't care yeah that fool was legit like
4 11. oh no yeah and then i think our
senior year of high school he shot up to
like five seven damn yeah out of nowhere
he had a growth spurt
dude i
that reminds me of my friend we were
both we're both five seven like senior
of high school i grew like an inch since
high school this guy grew to six foot
four holy [ __ ]
when i i caught up with him on social
media like what the [ __ ] like he's just
a [ __ ] i don't understand people who
grow an entire like foot
like who had those girls that was my my
best friend he was like 5 10 in high
school and then after we graduated i
went to riverside and then he went to
community college i came back over break
he shot up to six one he was my height
he shot like two three inches and so i
was like oh [ __ ] and i remember too like
he was he wasn't very strong he's
probably physically stronger than me now
yeah but i i
this will
since i was a kid i hate i hated lying
because my dad used to beat me to a
pulse because i would lie so much i had
a fan of lying yeah so it's like like we
understand what people tell fibs white
lies you exaggerate stories those aren't
really lies to me that's just being
entertaining speakers she's literally
like why are you late for work my tire
popped yeah [ __ ] like that so this full
it's just something small we were eating
like watermelon inside of my house right
and then this fool left all the scraps
on the table and i knew it was him
because i threw my [ __ ] away i was like
hey bros all your scraps he goes like no
that's yours
and that [ __ ] come on pissed me off yeah
and so i literally crossed his arms i
[ __ ] put my knee into his chest so
his arms were stuck onto his chest and i
sucked both of his arms until they went
numb
it's just the boys man what are you guys
what are you offended
man
with the guys dude remember [ __ ] we
used to play a game called bloody
knuckles
that's so dumb literally for you people
who don't know what bloody knuckles is
it's self-explanatory you just stick
your hand out and you go punch for punch
on each other's eyes the winner is the
one who's [ __ ] smarter yeah
they say
i'm done
we used to play [ __ ] open chest
you know what open chest is you just
stand there and it hit each other no you
it's it's it's ptsd so you're just
walking around school
and then if you're not guarding your
chest you get socked in it what so i
would just be eating like a salad or
something and all of a sudden one of my
friends would suck me in my chest in a
little open chest oh my gosh
and it got to the point one of my
friends
we just hung out recently when i went
back to sacramento this was like a world
international karate champion
you're not gonna stop his punch
i sort of got like he hit me once i
think i'd cough the blood like this will
hit me so [ __ ] hard oh my gosh and so
it got to the point where
this is also something dumb birthday
hits you know after a certain age it's
just getting jumped you know what's
dumber birthday shots oh yeah
taking as many shots as your birthday i
remember we stopped doing birthday hits
when we all hit 16. i was like you know
at this point you guys are just jumping
me into a gang yeah
yeah i better get something out of this
boys
yeah like i remember to like so
i avoided one of my friends and this guy
was [ __ ] strong as [ __ ]
this full i avoided him throughout all
all day
in high school because it was my
birthday yeah that was showed up to my
house and beat the [ __ ] out of me what
happy birthday [ __ ] yeah so because i
dodged like 10 punches oh so he just bum
rush into my house and finish the
punches
see you tomorrow oh god
the family's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
it's his birthday dude at that point
we're like you know what no more of this
stuff yeah like this is too much like
our
our arms would just be purple dude the
last time i played hit for hit
is with the wrong person i did it with a
kenny
[Laughter]
dog kenny's like 6'4 yeah i know which
is like i don't know why i agreed
he's a giant he's a giant i don't know
why i agreed and that's the last time i
played where i was like what 24 25 years
old oh my god that's still too old to be
playing
kenny is such a sweet guy too yeah
i can't believe he hit you it's because
he's so impulsive he's like you wanna go
hit for a hit and i'm a little impulse
too i was like yeah
let's just [ __ ] do it yeah let's do
it kenny by the way if you guys don't
know who's the lead singer of daphne
loves derby yeah he's a big tall guy
first of all saint yeah he's captain
korea yeah and like
i i know he would hate me like like you
know
spazzing him up like this
but like i said he's like six three six
four he's a good looking guy and he's a
[ __ ] genius
like and oh yeah he was a leader of a
band like playing arenas around the
country like [ __ ] girls in my high
school would masturbate to him yeah
they're like yeah some friends i'll meet
like they'll they'll see him in my
instagram they're like how are you
friends with him kind of thing yeah he's
my friend
he's a normal guy you know he's just
done extraordinary things like it's
nothing yeah he's an amazing human being
i call him captain korea like even his
grandpa his grandpa stole a train in
north korea to get them out
what he hijacked the train got like 150
people on and they rolled down to south
korea to safety well he's just a part of
a legacy yeah that's why i think that's
why he's like i got to live up to that
do you want to know my [ __ ] family
my [ __ ] family story during the time
during the korean war right [ __ ] was
going down this is the time for you to
stand up for your country my [ __ ]
grandfather the hero that he is got a
boat and fled and lived on the island
until the war was over
[Laughter]
which is exactly what i would have done
you know change was really nice
you know 1950 jeju island was very nice
so so my aunt
my oldest aunt right their their oldest
daughter was born on one of those
islands she doesn't have a birth
certificate whoa
so she doesn't she's not in the she's
not on the grid right so they had to
create one she doesn't even actually
know how old she is right she doesn't
know the actual date of her birthday the
actual date of her birth she was just
born on that island that a lot of people
fled to yeah and they just ran away and
then you have kenny scrap
flat north korea
that reminds me actually a few
thanksgivings ago um my
uncle my mom's oldest brother he's like
13 years older than her
um he just started telling us stories at
the dinner table down a little bit oh
sorry yeah he was uh telling stories at
the dinner table
and he told a story about our great uh
my great uncle
and
basically when
uh he was a child
uh
he
and my grandma and my great grandfather
were kidnapped
by like um some spies i think north
koreans
yeah
and they tied up my great grandfather to
a tree
while my grandma was holding on to him
you know crying and they [ __ ] killed
him they shot him point blank
because that's how i learned that my how
my grandma was deaf was because that
gunshot was so close to her ear
right
yeah
and and then those i get apparently
those guys like [ __ ] up my great uncle
too
and
and around that time they were living in
japanese occupation right yeah so
he was a freedom fighter as as a college
student and he was out there [ __ ] up
japanese government [ __ ] like being a
little gorilla terrorist
yeah well my grandpa's out here just
[ __ ] eating kimbap
yeah [ __ ] crazy so
so
throughout world war ii he was fighting
the japanese
and then after the japanese bounced and
they were trying to set up a new
government
um that's when
north and south korea got into their
civil war right yeah and he was a
democratic socialist he was saying but
like a [ __ ] guerrilla fighting
democratic socialist
and
so
he
he
uh initially wasn't really doing
anything for the war i guess because he
had already been fighting the japanese
yeah but then he got [ __ ] kidnapped
by guerilla fighters in the mountains
they kidnapped him and forced him to
fight with them
right and so he was just gone for years
they said and like like apparently like
the year following the war when it's
finally peace
they were all you know how korean
families all live in like one sugar
house yeah right the multi-generational
yeah
everybody's just sitting at home and um
they're on their front outdoor porch
thing
and then they said from far he said he
was a kid and he remembers this like
their house was like their front gate
was going right down the road and there
was a guy walking with a limp and with
like his arm in a sling like this
and he kept coming closer and closer and
closer and he said it was his uncle
right
and he was [ __ ] up he had like scars
all over his body like across his neck
he he was shot nine times and he was
walking finally walking home he goes um
and they're like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and
you finally made it home and so all my
other cousins say too yeah remember that
uncle his arms like this all the time
like i never met him
what
cousins know him yeah dude that's so
funny to me because
it all makes sense to him why my grandpa
never talks [ __ ] about japanese people
[Laughter]
so it's like i was a kid
you know that's why i didn't know about
all this like japanese korean animosity
yeah until college yeah because my
grandpa would be like yeah i could speak
some japanese he would show me like
japanese [ __ ] like it's nothing but his
experience was very different
you know he was over here fishing
yeah my grandma i think if you're korean
all your grandparents know japanese they
know how to speak japanese reading right
now because they were forced to they
were trying to just do a genocide and
get rid of our culture like cultural
genocide yeah yeah so they work out
books everything they turn that palace
that's in movies all the time now you
know that used to be a zoo for decades
for real yeah and the when they first
came in uh annexed korea they turned
that palace into a [ __ ] zoo they
destroyed everything in there and then
they just set up the whole courtyard and
all this [ __ ] to have animals live and
[ __ ] and piss in it
right and that's
crazy the hilarious thing is like
decades after the korean war it was
still a zoo they were like why the [ __ ]
is this a zoo
and they restored what they did was just
like one employee cleaning [ __ ] they're
like
bottom
what are we doing here why did we
maintain this like this is a palace yeah
so they they [ __ ] that's why you can
you see everybody taking pictures there
now because but it used to be a zoo for
a long time that's crazy man and when i
look back to i i don't know if this ever
blows people's mind this [ __ ] wasn't
really that long ago no it wasn't it was
literally just two generations for us
yeah and there's people still alive that
experienced this [ __ ] yeah people who
were like
like my grandma apparently got married
when she was 19 because her best friend
got kidnapped as a sex slave that's
crazy because her best friend when they
were afraid so what i also learned i saw
these old ass pictures of my hybrid he's
in japan
right and i'm like but my grandfather
isn't japanese yeah he was she just did
very well in korea
japanese occupied korea that he moved to
japan to become a scholar wow and
but through my grandma's connections
because my grandfather the reason why he
was kidnapped and murdered was because
he was a politician
in in the government and so
through that those connections
they
got my grandpa to marry my grandma so it
was an arranged marriage
what yeah slowly because it's like we
can't have her be a sex slave yeah
because they wouldn't i guess they
weren't like
kidnapping like married women apparently
at that time but they were kidnapping
teenagers
very much that's why they're still alive
today that's what's so crazy when i
would talk to like some of my friends
were japanese and like
they would ask their parents things
and you know how their parents would
describe it was
they didn't know what was going on
yeah like the citizens didn't know what
was going on yeah and especially like
culturally too you're just loyal to your
government so it wasn't this thing
that i think that a lot of people i mean
there could have been i don't know i
mean this is just from a perspective of
like these few people so mine's very
anecdotal based on like two or three
families they're like
yeah growing up we were just
living yeah you know we didn't know what
was going on like
we were kind of ignorant to everything
for me i i grew up so angry and pissed
off a because i didn't learn about any
of that [ __ ] in american schools right
yeah
it's when i went there's like a korean
holocaust museum in korea that i went to
when i was like 16. it blew my [ __ ]
mind because in eighth grade before that
when i was like 13 14 i went to
washington dc and went to the holocaust
museum there
right and it blew my mind like never
again
never let this happen
to you know
anybody or the world right and it was
all these like the jews were the example
of it right then i go to korea and i see
these atrocities
like that that were happening to us too
like these torture devices
and the the [ __ ] up [ __ ] they would do
like they would crucify the christians
like they brought back crucifixion yeah
like it was bad stuff god damn yeah uh
they'd cut off freedom fighters noses
and ears and send them and their lips
and send them back like without noses
and ears that's crazy yeah so they they
did some cruel [ __ ] right and so i grew
up really angry
a cause i didn't know until later in my
life
and and b
because i i yeah it wasn't taught in any
american schools but we learned about
the holocaust up our ass every year yeah
yeah and i don't know [ __ ] about the
holocaust yeah
really
like oh knew what i found out too it's
like i mean you don't really think about
this but every school's curriculum is
different based on like the demographics
of your school right so did you did you
did you read a raisin in the sun and
watched the play no see i did right so
did you learn about lewis and clark in
poke and not poke on sacagawea yeah oh
you did
that was like everything about
washington state yeah we did that but
like for example like black like black
culture in history was huge because you
know we had a huge uh black population
in our school right so we would watch
that's when cindy looks rest in peace
yeah so when he passed away i i know who
sydney poitiers be simply because i
loved his performance and raised in the
sun
so we read the play raised in the sun
and then we also watched it in class um
it was the black and white version where
cindy potato was the main character yeah
but to bring it back like i had
mentioned before i used to be a major
korean nationalist because of that hate
i carried but like it was only later in
life when i actually went to japan meet
and talk and live with the people that
it changed my obvious racism yeah but uh
and made me have a better understanding
like no this isn't the japanese people's
fault because at the same time they were
in [ __ ] internment camps yeah here in
this country yeah right it was war it
was world war ii right and i i can't say
it's the people but yeah
i still
to to release that hatred i had was like
there's love for the people but the
policies is still something like i get
irked about yeah like can you imagine if
germany never taught anything about
world war ii yeah and the [ __ ] they did
if they didn't have auschwitz memorial
either
same thing with um
what's it called um
i think it's like in the taiwanese
government too right
like they don't talk about like the
indigenous people there too or
it happens all over yeah it's kind of
crazy how it's just they just eliminate
like in china they do that the tnm's
it doesn't exist yeah it never [ __ ]
happened yeah
dude have you seen the real photos not
just the guy holding the bag yeah you
know when you scroll through reddit and
sometimes some [ __ ] up photo comes out
yeah it was like oh a real
behind-the-scenes photo
and it was just like
disgusting it was guts and body parts
spread everywhere everywhere yeah they
they didn't just like shoot and kill
them they desecrated their bodies yeah
it was pretty [ __ ] terrible but it's
not taught in their history books and
they act like it never [ __ ] happened
yeah which is damn near insane because
you know just to put it in perspective i
guess like if somebody were to listen to
this it's like
do you think [ __ ] america's hands are
like doesn't have any blood on it yeah
you know there are people who talk about
this country and what our military has
done to them which is why we have like
straight terrorist factions that hate
americans so much
and then let's say that we were to meet
these people and they go you're an
american we get killed for it right but
we're like wait i i just play nintendo
games
you know
what is this like i don't know what's
going on dude like after the first
invasion of iraq right
we
took it like in two weeks yeah right
fast but why were we there for like the
next 15 plus years
right
they were fighting insurrectionists not
terrorists that's what i had a problem
with too is that people got insurrection
and and um
terrorists like confused in these times
like uh
so after
they had defeated the saddam machine and
all that stuff
basically the people who were fighting
those soldiers were people who just
lived in iraq but they were throwing
ieds right and becoming terrorists right
and they were shooting at them but you
learned why why are they doing this
they're simply fighting back because
their american soldiers killed their
family yeah because they bombed their
home because they killed their children
and they're just like i have nothing to
lose now i'm gonna kill the people that
killed my kids yeah that's what was
going on so look at it in this
perspective
what if china with their
two they have like double the amount of
foot soldiers that americans do
what if those all those troops just
invaded the western side of america
right
and then they successfully defeated it
and and it was just run by these chinese
military everywhere they don't speak
your language and they don't look like
you yeah right
and they had already won right okay fine
we've surrendered peace
whatever but then all of a sudden every
now and then a bomb will hit your home
why are you still bombing us you won
yeah all of a sudden
a
like a soldier like shoots and kills
somebody driving a taxi he's just a taxi
driver he wasn't like some suicide
bomber kind of thing right over time
there's this resentment look
you can get
like i heard in afghanistan you can get
an ak for a pack of cigarettes
because there's just so many aks out
there god damn when i was out there
every home had an ak that's crazy they
have as many guns as we do
guess what yeah they're gonna use it
yeah yeah like all those guns that's
what the second amendment's for right if
there was you know like if our military
domestically gets overwhelmed then
citizens will take up arms yeah and
that's what the militias are for it's
exactly what we do and you know what
they would call themselves
insurrectionists
that's what's happening and but then
people will look at somebody like that
and call them a terrorist yeah instead
of saying hey what's our country doing
to them as a people
for them to do that and the you see all
these people like wow they hate us they
hate us because we got green hills and
rolling mountains and a beautiful flag
don't be mad you ain't got bald eagles
yeah you just got dust up your [ __ ]
yeah yeah
that's literally what i heard in high
school because you know i grew up in the
sticks that's everybody i hate us
because they live in [ __ ] dirt
don't hate us because you are peanuts
cause they're just jailors yeah it was
like that i and but as i went out there
in the middle east i kind of got a new
perspective like you watch star wars you
watch
even like any [ __ ] movie like where
the rebels are rising up against the
power
right
and who are the good guys in those
movies they're always the rebels yeah
you know i mean people just never know
what it's like until they actually go
there like yeah traveling and
experiences are or everything because
you can hear stories from people all the
time but unless you experience it you
smell feel all the stuff that happens
you don't really know you never get to
know right like this is a funny little
joke with a side story but this isn't
real [ __ ]
like i
grew up in an area that's very diverse
and next to my parents store was the
indian travel agency i've always loved
indian culture yeah yeah i know we would
do the indian accent whatever but i love
the indian culture like i've always
loved the food i loved like the weddings
the the [ __ ]
the music the culture all the other show
i always thought it was super
fascinating and i actually like i told
this story on the on the other podcast
with tim
but when i was a kid
um we used to call this uh store uh
punjabs
that's not the name of the store
what
when i went there not too long ago they
because they've seen me as a kid so
every time when i was a kid during my
the times i had breaks where my mom
would let me just go chill and do
nothing i would go over i would get
myself either a cold pickle
i would get a pickle where i would eat a
pickle spear or i get some hot pockets
funyuns hot cheetos and then like a
calypso lemonade or
or a [ __ ] soda or some [ __ ] right
so the guy remembers me he goes you know
i haven't seen you in such a long time
obviously with the thick you know accent
but
i think he
you guys have i i mean they'll probably
say it on the other podcast when it
comes out but i don't i'm not sure
exactly what these words mean but the
guy would use to teach me bad words
all the time so he would teach me this
word
i could probably just google it but i
don't know how to spell it because i'm
not sure if i'm saying it right but they
would say words like you would always
hear it all the time
means like either son of a [ __ ] or
bastard but he would teach me these
random words and i specifically remember
this one word that he would teach me and
it was like either gandu or gandu and i
think it means gay boy
i just remember walking around just
being like a gondo
you know just saying all this [ __ ]
but
this is [ __ ] with you yeah
i hope that's what those words mean i
don't know i don't remember exactly but
it was like son of a [ __ ] bastard or
gay boy i would look it up but i don't
know how to spell the words yeah you
know
but it was so interesting like like just
going to these cultures and you know
just to go back what i was talking about
i remember one time i was like yeah i
want to go go see india this was like
why
because
do you have family he's like
don't go
it's like it's it's
not good
don't go and i heard that twice i also
heard it from my friend rishi's parents
and they said the same thing i'm like oh
is it [ __ ] terrible over there
one of my other party told me like like
i said i've never been to india but
literally three people that i've known
growing up said
it's not that great yeah he goes like
yeah like you might like the culture and
stuff that you get to see here in the
states but yeah it goes india's pretty
impoverished like it's it's not as this
one of my buddies herself he goes have
you seen aladdin he goes that's what it
looks like
because if you're not in the nice areas
a lot of india is super impoverished so
like your ideal image of what you think
it is it's not like that yeah so i'm
like oh okay yeah i can even catch a
glimpse of it in like uh slumdog
millionaire right yeah yeah yeah yeah
but you know in film you always think
things are like super exaggerated yeah
but like from the way three people that
i know have told me they're like you
don't need to go
i've also heard from like my missionary
friends like the caste system out there
is like so rough that they they leave
their poor impoverished
gutter i'm once again if anybody who is
from india can explain this to me i
remember there was a girl in high school
right
at the time she wasn't my friend so i
didn't really know her that well
so
uh
i said her last name but it was the
wrong last name and i said her last name
was sing and she got hella mad really
she was like
excuse me i'm not a sing that's beneath
me it's what she said i was like what oh
so it's like seeing like a commenter's
name like in the cast system like that's
something like you wouldn't yeah because
i think her last name is uh
patel right so maybe patel is a lot
higher than singh i i don't know what it
was but the look of disgust that she had
when i when i thought her last name was
singh because i don't know it's like the
last name's the last name yeah you know
what i mean so the way that she said
that i was like oh is this because like
the cast system and like your name kind
of gives you like a level of who you are
in society right i i feel like yeah it's
like
so
it's really rough in the caste system
it's a it's a
because like they're they're they are a
homogeneous society right as far as
quote-unquote race goes yeah right but
they do have different languages because
it's such a big country yeah right i
mean there's like and different
fractions of like clans and cultures a
lot of different languages why i say
like i remember he was teaching me hindi
because it's like hindi gurati there's
like
punjabi there's all these different like
dialects and stuff yeah what my roommate
in when i was doing in my missionary
school was from india he flew in from
india but he looked chinese as [ __ ]
i'm like you're indian and he has like
an indian accent too get the [ __ ] out of
here but he's like no yeah i'm from
north east india like
right closer to like that
really it's kind of where the the border
of china and russia yeah so he's like
light-skinned more east asian looking
but he's like indian he's indian yeah so
that was something new i learned
you just met him he was like
hello yeah yeah i'm like oh dude what
are your parents like missionaries and
you're like bro that's really offensive
you know it's sad
no dude but like even the um the actor
who was the host in um who wants to be a
millionaire of slumdog millionaire
that guy
was complaining
like in the movie and he was angry that
um he he felt like he should have been
the star of the movie
because oh my god cause according to his
cast the cast system too he is higher
than the the actor who played the lead
role that's crazy how strong that [ __ ]
is yeah he was like super upset he's
like did you [ __ ] call me
sing
yeah
that's us like don't you dare call me a
[ __ ] kim yeah [ __ ] i'm not no
[ __ ] nam goons
i like i heard there's a lot of reason
the reason why we have so many kims is
because of like how big the clown had
the affluence a lot of people would lie
right right i've heard that too like
half the half the kim's in this world
aren't real kim's yeah so they would
just lie on their documents i think it
was because during the annexation like
apparently everyone had japanese names
too right
so after that uh that was over like
koreans had to
like [ __ ]
revive their identity
yeah so they chose a bunch of these last
names that's why it was like popular
names like
pac
and kim yeah so if you if you guys ever
wanted to know why korean people don't
have like a wide variation in last names
it's because it's clan based yeah it's
you are
some from the kim clan yeah okay so i
had this crazy experience this was like
[ __ ] damn it was 2007 i think
um i got
me and dan both got called to shoot a
documentary in korea for the holy wave
right that was the beginning stages of
the k-pop k-pop wave look at what it is
now but this was back in 2007 like we
were interviewing big bang when they
were little kids that's crazy and i
didn't know who the [ __ ] they were like
who are these freaking gay boys
obviously yeah it was this was during
the time yeah 2007.
yeah but like uh and then next thing i
knew like they were like the biggest
things in the world but um
we got invited to this dinner right and
um they were all like
uh people in the web space of asia
pretty much and so in that room
apparently with the ceos combined there
was about two billion dollars worth of
people in there
right damn what's the
the chinese google
uh a [ __ ] um weibo or something or i
can't remember i know what you're
talking about but
the [ __ ] i met that ceo oh really yeah
like he was there for that it it was
like for a g20
summit or something like that g some it
was a big summit for some wealth thing
um
like colin powell was part of that
summit too or whatever but at this
dinner specifically
i'm sitting next to
the ceo of this big software company and
you guys might know what it is i'm not
going to say it
um it's just
korean ajishi kind of guy and we were
done filming i could finally put my
camera down and i was seated next to him
right
and
uh
he
i was there with the guy who was
on donald trump's show uh
the apprentice he was a he was a
finalist on this
and that was part of the job i was with
so
this guy
he just starts talking [ __ ] about the
guy i'm with you know in front of him
yeah
does he know it's him
yeah he's like hey
how much do you think he's worth
and i was like i don't know like i know
he's successful in business in america
it's like but how much do you think
i was like well apparently he made his
first million in college
i was like and he goes okay let's say
he's worth 10 million dollars
generously and he's been saying all this
in english too by the way yeah he's
generously maybe he's worth 20 million
dollars right
and then he's like he's a clown
i'm like
and this guy's just over here eating
hey i'm sitting right here he's just
talking [ __ ] he's like that guy's a
clown he's like donald trump donald
trump's a clown you businessman or
entertainer
right he's like they're both clowns this
is 2007. holy [ __ ]
and then
he goes i'm worth 400 million dollars
i'm like
oh i would have looked at him
do you know how poor i am
why are you telling me this i feel
terrible and then he goes what's your
last name
i go park because i knew it
he goes i'm park he goes she's park he's
park he's park
and he's like we're family
right now it's like this [ __ ] right
he's like i was like really
he goes look at us our skin our hair
like you know how some koreans have that
look that mongolian look yeah that's
what he was talking about he's like look
at us yeah we're the same clan yeah
right so i have a daughter
yeah
you have a sex with your sister so he
goes he opens a bottle jack by the way
bottle of jack is like a hundred bucks
like out there because it's important
is it good because marshall he's like
take a drink i was like i drank too much
and he goes
yeah i was like this guy's worthless
yeah
i take a drink and i was drinking with
him and he was like for real about that
name like family club [ __ ] too
like for us like in america your name
doesn't really mean anything unless
you're like a socialite yeah you know
but they they say you're a hilton yeah
you know
like three parts removed i wish i was
there he's like what's your last name
it's oh something like
you didn't know yeah you dirty monkey
yeah
you don't sit next to us this is a park
table you clown yeah
mom's last name
park
park i swear dude and it's while they
they do like i had a friend who had a
big like park tattoo with
the original chinese symbol for it from
where like oh the hundred symbols yeah
like from way back where like he's like
do you know what kind of park you are
i'm like no
i was like
bro i'm just drunk
i'm [ __ ] dragged
i don't know i'm part of you now i guess
just like you said yeah you're gonna
pour me some jack too or what like what
the [ __ ] i feel like like i said it's
because it's a homogenous country right
it's more about classism than it's ever
about race yeah of course because
everybody's korean yeah so what else can
you do to separate you and [ __ ] show
that you're better than somebody besides
ethnicity at that point it's going to be
this whole caste system apparently
there's a law put into place in the
early 1900s
where it was where they had outlawed
classism because apparently it was a
problem 100 years ago too
i think it's i know for a lot of it what
had to do with jobs because they
recently um
made it uh illegal to
stop hiring people based on blood on
your blood type blood type yeah because
that's how serious is in korea but yeah
i get asked that by korean people like
what's your blood type in your so a
friend of mine who worked in korea years
ago was like i had to write my blood
type in my application for a job really
and they just oh we only hire you know
yeah
oh you're very very quick to anger yeah
so like you would they would like
certain i mean people who live in korea
could probably correct me if i'm wrong
but this is coming from a person that i
know he said that on an application he
had to write his a blood type
they asked his blood type on an
application job application my goodness
isn't that [ __ ] crazy is that like
outlawed here in america because of
hippa
a blood type damn
there because i mean it's a preconceived
notion of who it's like basically asking
somebody hey so what's your [ __ ] sign
yeah what's your myers-briggs
job application your pisces we don't
hire pisces yeah
aries uh you're gonna be too much of a
leader in this group so i don't think so
that's that's wild it's just this odd
thing too like asian people and that
blood type [ __ ] it's like for my mom
used to mention that [ __ ] to me all the
time she goes you're a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] cause you're type b
that's such a type b type of thing yeah
i hear that i i've heard i've always had
to ask my mom what my blood type is
because someone would ask me about my
personality and then i'd always forget
because it's not important to me
i'm like i don't know that's my doctor
they know yeah it's probably important
to for medical reasons like if i'm
losing blood really i should probably
remember i feel like
i could just picture you and do a major
car accident and they have to give you
an immediate blood transfusion like
what's your blood type you're like you
[ __ ] classes
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast what are your
thoughts on classes and award shows once
again just to reiterate i have
nothing against anybody who loves award
shows it's just not something that i
grew up with it always makes me feel
weird it feels like i have to suck my
own dick and i just yeah i just don't
like it you know but once again if you
love awards this is what you grew up
with hey [ __ ] kudos to you man you
grew up in an environment of positive
reinforcement i was called a loser my
whole life
and anytime i got a war they were like
everybody gets that award yeah
so we all grew up differently man but
you could catch ed at ed parkvp
and you could catch genius brains at
geniusbrain at 12 p.m every sundays
until further notice uh secret society
is the clothing line if you see the cap
s-c-r-t s-o-c-i-e-t-y.com
it's one of my bigger passions right now
it's me bringing contemporary fashion
basics with just the right quality um
and i know you guys hear about quality
all the time we did a previous podcast
about this but um knowing about clothes
and just creating clothes are two
different things that we're trying to
disrupt the clothing system with the
[ __ ] that we do so hope you guys check
that out and we'll see you all next time
peace peace